Trump is thinking in a nuanced way about
major political issues notably foreign
policy do you want Ukraine to win this
War I don't think in terms of winning
and losing I think in terms of getting
it settled so we stop killing all these
people and breaking them
can you say if you want Ukraine or
Russia to win this war I want everybody
to stop dying they're dying Russians and
ukrainians I wanted to stop dying say
this I want Europe to put up more money
because they're in for 20 billion we're
in for 170 and they should answer and
they should equalize Trump knows that if
he says I want Ukraine to win first of
all you're going to just be affirming
what Russia's already said which is that
the U.S is a belligerent in the Ukraine
war and the U.S is not just waging a
kind of cold war here that the U.S is
waging a hot war with Russia you're only
going to escalate that which is what all
the Liberals and the Hawks are doing on
this particular issue and Trump says no
I just want to wind down the conflict